charles aznavour est un géant de 83 ans
à 1063 la ville mais il ment sur la
scène une carrière démesuré 65 ans de
succès internationaux 740 chansons dont
150 en anglais lui qui incarne la
chanson française dans le monde entier
aurait pu devenir américain si ses
parents réfugiés en france avait obtenu
leur visa pour les etats unis nous
l'avons échappé belle rue ce recueil de
nouvelles
mon père ce géant chez flammarion aborde
des thèmes tels que la solitude la
compassion et la fois dans son journal
intime
il revient sur sa famille ses origines
nous parle de sa diaspora arménienne
nous explique ce que veut dire penser
piaf et nous révèle qu'un grand chanteur
peut avoir perdu de l'oreille
[Musique]
for me for me formidable héritage
j'aime bien briser les tabous mais
par exemple pour les gens qui
n'entendent pas bien pourquoi ne pas le
dire moi ne sais pas je le dis mais je
le montre mon ami mon ami c'est lui qui
n'en a pas besoin
il est ivre il fait la publicité qu'on
vient demander le faire mais en même
temps fait la publicité à la ville il
dit aux gens mais non mais si tu attends
pas bien je vais te dire ce que tu vas
faire je vais présenter quelqu'un vient
je connais un métier formidable c'est
encore plus fort que moi parce que moi
je le dis parce que ça m'est arrivé
lui il le dit de rien c'est bon non
mon père était baryton il joue aussi la
comédie et ma mère était actrice
meilleur elle souffle les paroles des
chansons de mon père avait oublié dont
on a toujours chanté et joué la comédie
dans la famille finalement mes parents
faisaient du théâtre tous les quinze
jours à peu près dans les pièces
arménienne dans des salles inconnu mais
c'était leur bonheur parce que ils ont
été vus fuir d'autres métiers pour
pouvoir survivre et élever leurs enfants
mon père était un homme qui aimait
l'être humain il était toujours les
autres et chez moi nous avons ma soeur
et moi push est souvent par faire parce
qu'ils ont donnée les sommiers aux gens
qui passaient et houleux où le matelas
parce que c'était meilleur et nous on
dormait d'une manière inconfortable mais
en fait il avait le don de donner le don
d'ouvrir la porte
le don d'oublier l'heure qu'il est si
quelqu'un arrive à n'importe quelle
heure ils entraient et comme mon père
faisait bien la cuisine et vise avec
cuisine pour celui qui venait chez une
famille exemplaire
des parents qui étaient non seulement
très aisément mais qui est aussi
ouvert moderne je crois qu'on était à
l'époque la famille arménienne la plus
moderne de paris et j'ai hérité de tous
de mes parents et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des parents qui ont compris ce
qu'on voulait faire ma soeur et moi et
qu'ils nous ont laissé faire on l'aurait
pu rater il avait confiance et moi j'ai
dit optimiste
la subissons sera douce et tendre
mon père était né en géorgie mais cher
donc il était géorgien et ma mère ma
mère qu'elle arrêtait était né en
turquie
elles étaient turcs en fait le génocide
il a fait quoi
il a tué des gens du pays parce que pour
moi si demain il y avait investi en
france et qu'on tue en occupant un
arménien ont tué un français je suis
français avant tout ce n'est pas mon
peuple
mais c'est ma diaspora c'est une culture
intérieure parce qu'une bonne culture
parce que nous sommes mariés totalement
à la culture du pays dans le guide
enlevé par exemple c'est étonnant aux
états unis heather munroe deux têtes de
plus que moi
ils ressemblent aux américains ils
finissent par ressembler aux américains
et nous ressemblent aux français vous
pouvez pas dire que j'ai une tête
d'arméniens alors avec la meilleure
volonté du monde
quand je vais dans le monde on voit
parisien le soleil brille à plein
mieux
je ne vois que tu es
j'aime bien écrire pour les femmes parce
que je me mets à leur place et au début
lorsque j'écrirai j'écrivais avec un
miroir devant - pour pouvoir pas
uniquement ressentir les émotions mais
vous voir l'acteur joué la petite
partition j'étais en train d'écrire plus
maintenant il ya longtemps que shazam a
quitté je suis devenu donc peut-être
plus habiles dans la manière de me
demander
droit
[Musique]
et
se prendre en main
spir
lorsque je travaille avec edith et je
pensais pas à grand-chose j'étudiais je
regardais piaf je voyais ce qu'elle
faisait de formidables et je voyais
aussi les erreurs qu'elle faisait ses
erreurs dans la vie il faisait pour les
erreurs sur scène je pense que c'était
une femme qu'il connaissait parfaitement
son métier
et lorsque j'ai débuté seul vraiment
je me suis posé la question et longtemps
et souvent qu'est ce qui est dit aurait
chanté en entrée de seine si elle avait
mon répertoire à moi et qu'est-ce
qu'elle aurait placé ensuite et en
pensant piaf je ne me suis jamais trompé
parce qu'elle savait exactement ce qu'il
fallait faire
[Musique]
le succès c'est une hallucination
collective c'est dire que le succès
c'est pas une personne qui vous dit vous
êtes grands vous êtes vous êtes mes yeux
c'est tous les gens qui sont installés
dans cette salle sont lincou qui vous
reçoivent qui vous reçoivent bien ou mal
mais quand c'est bien l'hallucination
est formidable mais sinon dans les
variétés faut pour le comprendre mais
quand même faut pas faut pas se lever le
collet et se relever le mur en disant
moi je suis un artiste de variété moi je
trouve qu'il faut être très humble et je
dis souvent amusant au public vous savez
c'est vous qui m'avez tous payés car
c'est vrai en plus s'ils n'étaient pas
là qu'est ce que j'aurais moi rien
qu'est-ce que je serais un épicier
arméniens ont intérieur ou encore de
nier ou un bottier c'est ce qu'on
apprenait quand j'étais quand j'étais
enfant on après des métiers parce que
parce que les anciens disaient
d'ailleurs tu peux aller dans n'importe
quel pays du monde
tu n'as pas besoin de connaître la
langue et oui mais dans la chanson faut
connaître la langue c'est la seule
différence
je me pose toutes les questions mais
c'est difficile de poser une question à
moi même je la vie n'est faite que de
questions je ne pose que des questions
je n'écris que car en répondant à
quelque chose
non je n'ai rien à me demander ça me
donne une liberté
[Musique]